D
TO MY KNOWLEDGE AND HISTORY OF
HIS COUNTRY, AND I CALL ON YOU
TO RESIGN.
>> Tucker: SO, GLENN YOUNGKIN
IS RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA AS A REPUBLICAN AND HAS
FOUND HIMSELF RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS DEBATE.
HE COULD WIN ON THIS.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
GLENN YOUNGKIN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS RACE THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE ABOUT THAT THIS
QUESTION.
SHOULD PARENTS HAVE ANY
INFLUENCE OVER THEIR OWN
CHILDREN?
WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT IT TURNS
OUT THERE PEOPLE WHO THINK
PARENTS DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
INFLUENCE THEIR OWN KIDS?
>> WELL, TUCKER, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME TONIGHT.
NO, I AM NOT SURPRISED, BECAUSE
VIRGINIA'S PARENTS ARE
PARTICULARLY LOUD IN COUNTY
WHERE IT HAS BEEN GROUND ZERO,
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO STAND
UP FOR THEIR KIDS FOR THE LAST
20 MONTHS.
OPEN OUR SCHOOLS, STOP TEACHING
OUR KIDS WHAT TO THINK AND TEACH
THEM HOW TO THINK.
MAKE SURE WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THE CLASSROOM.
MY OPPONENT, HE STOOD THERE AND
SAID NO, PARENTS DO NOT HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE CLASSROOM.
IN FACT, HE DOUBLED DOWN AND
TRIPLED DOWN AND QUADRUPLED DOWN
ON IT AND JUST YESTERDAY, YOU
KNOW, HE WAS WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN YESTERDAY, AND
I'M SURE THEY DISCUSSED THIS.
HE COULD HAVE TOLD
PRESIDENT BIDEN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN, I'M SIDING WITH
PARENTS BECAUSE IN VIRGINIA, BY
THE WAY, PARENTS HAVE A LEGAL
RIGHT TO MAKE DECISIONS WITH
REGARDS TO THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION.
IT IS A LEGAL RIGHT IN VIRGINIA.
AND TERRY McAULIFFE TOLD
PRESIDENT BIDEN, IF HE COULD, HE
DIDN'T, HE SHOULD CHANGE THAT.
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY,
MERRICK GARLAND, HE DOUBLED DOWN
AND SAID NO.
I AM ABSOLUTELY MAINTAINING MY
POSITION.
THAT THE DOJ AND FBI SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATING PARENTS.
PARENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO STAND
UP FOR THEIR CHILDREN WHEN THERE
HAS BEEN A SEXUAL ASSAULT IN A
SCHOOL BATHROOM, AND WE HAVE A
BOARD -- A BOARD OF EDUCATION IN
LOUDOUN COUNTY THAT TRIED TO
HIDE IT FROM PARENTS, HIDE IT
FROM THE PUBLIC.
AND MOVE FOR THIS CHILD INTO
ANOTHER SCHOOL.
AND THEN THAT CHILD AGAIN
COMMITTED ANOTHER
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I HAVE CALLED FOR A FULL
INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE CALLED FOR AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE SCHOOL
BOARD, THE COMMONWEALTH
ATTORNEY, THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT.
I'LL TELL YOU, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD RESIGN AND
OH, BY THE WAY, THE FBI SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATING THESE FOLKS,
TOO.
THIS IS JUST ABSOLUTELY
UN-AMERICAN.
AND AS GOVERNOR IN VIRGINIA, I'M
GOING TO STAND UP FOR PARENTS, I
AM GOING TO STAND UP FOR
CHILDREN, I AM GOING TO STAND UP
FOR THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS FOR
PARENTS TO MAKE DECISIONS WITH
REGARDS TO THEIR KIDS EDUCATION.
THIS HAS ABSOLUTELY GOT TO STOP
AND THAT IS WHY I AM RUNNING,
TUCKER, BECAUSE IT IS TIME FOR
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY TO WIN OVER
BIG GOVERNMENT CONTROL AND MY
OPPONENT TERRY McAULIFFE
BELIEVES IN BIG GOVERNMENT
CONTROL AND I BELIEVE IN PARENTS
RIGHTS WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION, TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, WHAT THEY
ARE REALLY SAYING IS WE ARE YOUR
CHILDREN'S PARENTS AND YOU ARE
NOT, AND BASED ON THAT ALONE, WE
ARE ROOTING FOR YOU, GLENN
YOUNGKIN, ON TUESDAY IN
VIRGINIA.
THANKS SO MUCH F